president Trump's promise of a southern
border wall is beginning to take shape
in Texas CBS News got exclusive access
to this construction site in Donna where
an 8 mile stretch of wall costing about
a hundred sixty-seven million dollars is
being built
Mireya Villarreal is there Maria is this
evidence the president's keeping his
promise well you know answer you take a
look this is the old wall that was built
during the Bush administration if we
walk about 20 feet over here there is
new construction and I promise it is
there behind all of that fog and as you
mentioned this was a big campaign
promise for President Trump
however this wall is not going to
stretch all along the southern border
and it is already facing some legal
fights from local landowners what's the
reality of illegal drug smuggling here
especially in South Texas the reality is
it's all around you border patrol sector
chief Rudy Karthik is overseeing this
new 8 mile stretch of border wall in the
Rio Grande Valley just a half a mile
from the river the goal to stop illegal
human and drug smuggling this
administration has made it clear they
want to help us by giving us the tools
that we need to be more effective is the
wall the answer to everything
no of course not it can never be a wall
is not going to make an arrest however
if you have piece of tactical
infrastructure in place maybe that
person is going to decide that I'm not
going to cross in this location I'm
going to go somewhere else
9 projects are funded in the valley for
a hundred and nine miles of new wall
part of a larger almost ten billion
dollar government effort to reinforce
the border but it's not quite the
concrete while the president promised on
the campaign trail in 2016 the windows
know nothing precast concrete going very
high the only concrete is on the bottom
to keep floodwaters away from local
landowners as the president continues to
boast about the walls effectiveness and
impending completion there are still
apparent cracks in the process the
social media video shows two men
recently scaling a portion of
refurbished wall in California the
United States government is abusing us
landowners are also feeling the pressure
ray Cavazos and his family have owned
about 69 acres of land along the border
for Gen
they worried the government will take
their property next to them the wall is
a waste of money how long do you fight
we're gonna fight as long as it takes we
know that it's very difficult to fight
the government but we're gonna hang in
there as long as we can this project is
set to be done in January of 2021 but
this is a very active area for illegal
activity Border Patrol agents telling us
ground sensors just went off not too far
from here this morning right now the
chief is telling me he wants all of
these projects done by the end of next
year Tony yeah thank you very much